[Musique]
je t'ai observé il faut que tu te
souviennes j'ai vu quelqu'un la mamba
ils n'étaient pas humains
c'est un criminel connu et il a tué à
nouveau
il n'a pas fait que ça il a acquis leur
cerveau il est partout et nulle part je
vais le trouver et je vais le tuer
[Musique]
tu parles jamais ton passé je me
souviens pas grand chose que des bribes
il y a eu une attaque
tu allais mourir nous avons sauvé et
maintenant tu en sors d'autres
tout ce qu'ils t'ont racontée est un
mensonge
tu avais une famille souviens toi de ça
qu'est ce que tu es
tu es belle
qu'est ce que tu veux de moi
ils ne t'ont pas sauvé la vie il te
l'ont volé
il y en a eu combien avant moi
il était prévu que son cerveau soit
vierge
détruisez là
major
ils m'ont créé mais elles ne peuvent pas
me contrôler
[Musique]